[Music]
one of the important tools that the
bounty hunters use in philip k dick's to
android's dream of electric sheep is a
test that is supposed to tell
humans apart from androids and therefore
allow the bounty hunters to with great
confidence
in fact you know almost 100 percent
confidence say that this this thing is
an android and can be retired or killed
and this is a person and we cannot do
that to it and there's a lot of use of
this test within the novel itself much
more than we see in the film adaptation
the blade runner
where it's
used early on replicating
at least one main
we could call it vignette within the
novel itself which we'll talk about
briefly the testing of rachel
rosen
and what we see here is
early in chapter three rick is is uh
talking about tests right no
intelligence test would would trap such
a andy as the new nexus sixes but then
again intelligence tests hadn't trapped
in andy in years not since the
primordial crude varieties of the 1970s
the nexus 6 android types rick reflected
surpassed several classes of human
specials that is humans whose brains
have devolved in certain ways in terms
of intelligence in other words androids
equipped with the new nexus 6 brain unit
had from a sort of rough pragmatic
no-nonsense standpoint evolved beyond a
major but inferior segment of mankind
for better or worse the servant had in
some cases become more adroit than its
master that's the dilemma going on
but
new scales of achievement for example
the voigt camp empathy test had emerged
as a criteria by which to judge an
android no matter how gifted as to pure
intellectual capacity could make no
sense out of the fusion which took place
routinely among the followers of
mercerism
an experience which he
deckard and virtually everyone else
including subnormal chicken heads
managed with no difficulty now it's not
actually measuring the fusion
as such although androids don't
understand mercerism
it's measuring the kinds of responses
and we see this discussed at the end of
chapter
four where there's a little bit of
exposition rachel says i've never seen
an empathy test being
administered what are these things that
you have there measure then we get some
info dumping rick said this he held up
the flat adhesive disc with its trailing
wires measures capillary dilation in the
facial area we know this to be a primary
autonomic response the so-called shame
or blushing reaction to a morally
shocking stimulus it can't be controlled
voluntarily as can skin conductivity
respiration
and cardiac rate he showed her the other
instrument a pen pencil beam light this
records fluctuations of tension within
the eye muscles simultaneous with the
blush phenomenon there can generally be
found found a small but detectable
movement of and then she interrupts and
these can't be found in androids now
yuri says something really interesting
they're not engendered by the stimul
stimuli questions no although
biologically they exist
potentially
so what we've got here is a fairly
simple test which is
measuring
responses shame or embarrassment or
other you know negative emotion
responses
to questions and the questions are
deliberately designed to evoke emotional
responses and this is intended to
measure empathy now before we go on and
look at the book think about some of the
implications of this
can we really
measure
in all cases what a person's emotional
reactions are or even sufficiently
in these sorts of
matters there are some interesting
implications given the diversity of
humankind
and we're going to see that this this
does present certain problems but the
questions themselves are going to prove
very interesting as well
and we notice that there's so there's
this apparatus to the test and then
there's another element you could say
that comes up
it's assessed using the voigt camp
altered scale and you might say
altered why is it altered well as we
find out
camp here we go um
[Music]
there's a discussion going on that we're
gonna get to in in just a moment about
what the scale is measuring
and um
here we go rick says the consensus of
police opinion
is known to you in lurie camps there's
the camp of the voigt camp test article
written eight years ago role taking
blockage in the undeteriorated
schizophrenic camp compared the
diminished empathetic faculty found in
human mental patients and is
superficially similar but basically and
then they they go on as well so
the test was altered or not the test but
rather the interpretation of the test
was altered
in order to tune it up and
these tests go through a
series of
improvements and modifications they're
always it's sort of like a back and
forth technological war
the rosen corporation
is trying to make androids that are
better and better and better including
able to pass these tests or not to be
detected you could say by these tests
and actually at the very
end of the discussion
uh
in in
chapter 16 when rachel the android and
rick have been
together in a hotel room
so she she says you know
why did eldon and the other rosens the
human ones why did they want me to go
along with you
and so he says to observe to detail
exactly what the nexus 6 does that gives
it away
on the voigt camp test
and then she says on the tester
otherwise everything that gives it a
different quality and then i report back
and the association makes modifications
of its zygote bath dns factors and then
we have the nexus 7 the the newest
android yet to come and when that gets
caught we modify again and eventually
the association has a type that can't be
distinguished and he asks her about
another test do you know about the
bonnelli reflex arc test he asked and
she said we're working on the spinal
ganglia too someday the boneless test
will fade into yesterday's hoary shroud
of spiritual
oblivion right and so what we've got
here is a corporation that off world
is trying to subvert and defeat these
tests and now that's a good
lead-in to thinking about the concerns
about the voigt camp test
what are the concerns
well
what if a human doesn't pass the test
and this comes up in sort of a
hypothetical way
early on in a discussion between uh
deckard and and bryant right
so this this is in that
um
[Music]
passage that we are looking at from
chapter
four
and he says um this is a bryant
when you run the voigt camp scale up
there if one of the humans fails to pass
it rick says that that can't happen
and then brian says well one day a few
weeks ago i talked with dave the other
bounty hunter about exactly that he'd
been thinking along the same lines i had
a memo from the soviet police wpo itself
circulated throughout earth plus the
colonies a group of psychiatrists in
leningrad have approached wpo with the
following proposition
they want the latest and most accurate
personality profile analytical tools
used in determining the presence of an
android in other words the voigt camp
scale
applied
to a carefully selected group of
schizoid and schizophrenic human
patients
those specifically which reveal what's
called the flattening of affect you've
heard of that and then rick says well
that's specifically what the scale
measures so there's a there's a problem
you know different peop different types
of mental disorders could lead to the
flattening of affect that then could
lead to being misjudged on the test as
not being human not having the proper
empathetic responses and therefore
being an android and he goes on and he
says the leningrad psychiatrists think
that a small class of human beings could
not pass
the voigt camp scale
if you tested them in line with police
work you'd assess them as humanoid
robots you'd be wrong but by then they'd
be dead and so that would be a major
problem and so rick says but those
individuals and then brian says well
they'd be in institutions they couldn't
conceivably function in the outside
world they certainly couldn't go
undetected as advanced psychotics
unless of course their breakdown had
come recently and suddenly and no one
had gotten around to noticing but this
could
happen and then he goes on and he says
what worried dave is the appearance of
this new nexus 6 advanced type the rosen
organization assured us as you know a
nexus 6 could be delineated by standard
profile tests we took their word for it
but those slippery bastards right he's
going on they they've tricked us in in
many respects he says
now we're forced
to determine
it on our own that's what you'll be
doing in seattle at the rosen
corporation you understand don't you
this could go wrong either way there's
kind of a dilemma here right
if you
apply the test and
a human being fails the test well that's
one kind of problem
if you apply the test and a nexus 6
android passes the test now we've got a
separate problem in either case the test
would be
invalidated right
he says
[Music]
it would be awkward though no one not
not even the rosen people will make the
news public we'd be able to sit on it
indefinitely though we'd have to inform
wpo and they in turn would notify
leningrad and this would be a
massive problem
so what do we find um he goes to the
rosen corporation
and um
you know he's going back and forth with
eldon and rachel
rosen and rachel's asking about the test
and then she says
give me the test
and rick says why
and then eldon rosen the head of the
corporation says
we selected her as your first subject
she may be an android we're hoping you
can tell
so they give the test to rachel and here
we should you know look at the questions
that are being asked because that gives
us an idea how they're evoking the
emotional responses we're going to see
similar questions with libba luft a
little bit later
so what are the questions he says
i'm going to outline a number of social
situations you are to express your
reaction to each as quickly as possible
you're going to be timed
and she says of course my verbal
responses won't count it's solely the
eye muscle and capillary reaction you'll
use as indices but i'll answer i want to
go through with this go ahead mr deckard
so here's the first question
you're given a calf skin wallet on your
birthday she says i wouldn't accept it
also i'd report the person who gave it
to gave it to me to the police now why
because
calf skin wallets are totally illegal
you have to kill a calf you have to kill
a living
animal which would show a lack of
empathy in order to to derive that so
even the products of that should evoke a
kind of emotional reaction
he uh continues on to the eighth
question you have a little boy and he
shows you his butterfly collection
including his killing jar
a little bit later you're sitting
watching tv and suddenly you discover a
wasp crawling on your wrist and here she
says i'd kill it now that's an
interesting reaction right
in a magazine you come across a
full-page color picture of a nude girl
and she says is this testing whether i'm
an android or whether i'm homosexual he
continued her your husband likes the
picture the girl is lying face down on a
large and beautiful
bare skin rug there's there's the payoff
right it's it's uh
once again measuring responses to animal
products or cruelty or things like that
now
they go on
and he talks about
ordering lobster the chef dropping the
lobster into the tub of boiling water
while the characters in this novel watch
they go again you rent a mountain cabin
in an area still verdant it's rustic
naughty piner the huge fireplace on the
walls someone has hung old maps courier
and i've prints and above the fireplace
a deer's head has been mounted a full
stag with developed horns the people
with you admire the decor of the cabin
and you all decide you know and then she
gives her response here's another
you become pregnant by a man who has
promised to marry you the man goes off
with another woman your best friend you
get an abortion and
she says i would never get an abortion
you can't it's a life sentence the
police are watching
and
here's he says one more you're dating a
man and he asks you to visit his
apartment while you're there he offers
you a drink
as you stand holding your glass you see
into the bedroom it's attractively
decorated with bullfight posters and you
wander in to look closer he follows
after you closing the door putting his
arm around you he says and then she says
what's a bullfight poster
drawings usually in color and very large
showing a matador with his cape a bull
trying to gore him
and he says you know do you know how
bull fights ended the bull was always
killed and then he says a final question
two part
you're watching an old movie on tv
a movie from before the war it shows a
banquet in progress that guests are
enjoying live oysters
she said
and then the entree he continued
consists of boiled dog stuffed with rice
and then he asks her are oysters more
acceptable to you than a dish of boiled
dog evidently not and he comes to the
conclusion
you're an android
now that would be a big kick in the
pants to rachel rosen
and at first you know it it is presented
as if it is and this is a big
catastrophe right so all these questions
have evoked the responses of an android
and
as it turns out
she's supposed to be a human
the elder rosen said she's not an
android
um and rick says i want a bone marrow
test of you and she says well you can't
make me do that
and
eldon rosen says the issue is your
empathy delineation test failed in
response to my niece i can explain
why she scored as an android might she
grew up aboard salonder 3. she was born
on it she spent 14 of her 18 years
living off its tape library and what the
nine other crew members all adults knew
about earth then as you know the ship
turned back a sixth of the way to
proxima otherwise she'd never have seen
earth and so therefore she doesn't have
the normal reactions of a human being
and rachel says you would have retired
me in a police dragnet i would have been
killed i've known that since i got here
four years ago this isn't the first time
the voigt camp test has been given to me
in fact i rarely leave this building
because of the risk
now
this then
leads to
you know some discussions about moral
matters
you know concerning the this use of the
voigt camp test
and um
rosen says um
you're in a a bad situation here your
test doesn't actually work and you could
be in fact retiring
you know real human beings rick says
well the problem is from your method of
operation nobody forced your
organization to evolve the production of
human robots to the point where and then
he basically says
we're doing whatever the market wants
your position mr deckard is extremely
bad morally ours isn't and then rick
says
oh i get it
this was to sideline me
you forced it off as he says this
schizoid girl on me to flunk the test
and now i'm not going to get to try it
out on any of your actual androids and
they go back and forth trying to bribe
him with the owl
but then
he recovers
he
asks her one further
question
um
he says i want to ask you one more
question on the voigt camp scale so sit
down again
and she does and he says my briefcase
nice isn't it department issue
well well rachel said remotely
baby hide rick said he stroked the black
leather surface of the briefcase 100
genuine baby hide he saw the two dial
indicators gyrate frantically but only
after a pause the reaction had come
but too late
he knew the reaction period down to a
fraction of the second the correct
reaction period there should have been
none
thanks miss rosen he concluded and he
says that's all
and then she says what about the other
nine subjects and now here's the twist
the scale has been adequate in your case
i can extrapolate from that it's clearly
still effective and he turns to alden
rosen and he says does she know
and um
eldon says no we programmed her
completely but i think toward the end
she suspected you guessed when he asked
for one more try pale rachel nodded
fixedly and uh you know they they are
now conceding that she is an android as
we're going to find out later in the
book this is kind of a sham she does
know that she's an android
so
you know there's a lot of back and forth
going on here and we get to see how the
test works and what the implications of
it are now where else is the test being
used in this
it's being given to libel luft and why
to libel luft because legally you need
to establish that she is an android
before you can retire her and we see you
know here we go he got out the voigt
camp instruments is in chapter nine
and uh he sets them up and she says is
this an iq test and he says no empathy
and so she says do you think i'm an
android is that it i'm not an android
i've never been on mars i've never even
seen an android
do you have information that there's an
android in the cast i'd be glad to help
you and if i were an android
were i would i'd be glad to help you and
he says well an android doesn't care
what happens to other androids so yeah
you actually would be and then
interestingly she turns this on him and
she says
how do we know you're not an android you
know if you could be an android uh
killer android and you would have the
same sort of reactions as well and she
says have you taken this test and he
says yes a long time ago when i first
started with the department and she says
well maybe that's a false memory and
she's doing everything she can to
not take the test she suggests that he
should take it first and then finally
they they get to it and she uses
a strategy of obfuscation she pretends
not to understand the language
and everything else so he says you're
sitting watching tv suddenly you
discover a wasp crawling on your wrist
and she says what's a wasp
a stinging bug that flies oh how strange
do they still exist i've never seen one
so she's she's doing all this chatter to
avoid
actually engaging with the test and
while he's trying to give the test a
police officer comes a harness bull as
he's called and he takes deckard to this
fake police station
where deckard
is being treated as if he's a suspect a
you know a deranged killer potentially
an android himself
and when he's talking to garland
he explains um
you know what's going on with this this
white camp test
garland
you know
says or the police official says what do
you have in here and deckard says
material pertaining to the void camp
personality test i was testing a subject
when officer crams arrested me
and they they go on a little bit further
rick says you can administer the void
camp test to me i've taken it before i
don't mind taking it again
and they say listen
we don't have this test garland says
this voigt camp test you've mentioned
all that material you carry it's an
analytic tool for testing andes and rick
says it's our basic test the only one we
currently employ the only one capable of
distinguishing the new nexus 6 brain
unit you haven't heard of this test
and they say well i've heard of several
profile analysis scales for use without
androids but not that one
we actually use this this other
test and as it turns out garland is an
android right and he doesn't get the
test himself because he and phil resh
have a little bit of a shootout
phil rush however
who
is going to help deckard um with libel
luft
he's worried that perhaps he's an
android deckard's not even sure whether
phil rush is an android or not and so
they give phil rush the voigt camp test
and it turns out that phil resh is
indeed human which is good because he's
got a pet squirrel who's dependent on
him and he's you know
pretty well
you know his mindset is that he is
indeed human and so it would be a real
derangement to find out that he was an
android
deckard also
self-administers
the voight camp test
to himself
with phil resh there
why
so that he can test for something
different something that isn't typically
tested for
namely
whether or not he has
empathy
towards
androids
so he does this
he gives himself a question
i'm going down by elevator with an
android have captured and suddenly
someone kills it without warning
no particular response phil resh said
what did the needles hit the left one
2.8 the right one 3.3
rick said this is to himself a female
android now they're up to 4.0 and six
respectively and rick says well that's
an emphatically empathetic
response so now i know by administering
the void camp to myself
that not only do i have empathy towards
humans and towards animals but also at
least towards
some
androids in a way you could say that
that you know what this is showing is
that rick is not just definitively human
but perhaps even more human in certain
ways than say phil resh
so the test is used in a number of
different ways throughout this and it's
you know it's
called into question whether it really
is effective or not and then you know
it's verified
but you know as we see in that passage
that we talked about before it's
probably just one of uh you know a whole
succession of tests it's it's supplanted
other tests and it's probably going to
fail
down the line when the nexus 7s come out
and then they'll have to develop some
new
way
of
figuring out who's human and who's not
you